we're here in DC to introduce you to the
10 lawmakers that you need to watch the
ones whose names you're going to be
hearing more about and whose policy
decisions will impact your daily life
the most so let's head inside the
Capitol and meet up with Senator Mark
Warner from Virginia
I'm really lucky because of all 535
members House and Senate I actually live
closer to the Capitol than any other
member I usually get up and work out
pretty early I then get a binder that
gives me what I do all day a lot of
times my real day starts about five
o'clock and goes till 9 30 or 10 most
nights so I'm not a great breakfast
person but I can hit three or four
cocktail parties in an evening
[Music]
it's my background before I was a
Senator was in technology I was a
Wireless Communications guy got involved
in cell phones early on was a venture
capitalist Midway through my career I
got on the intelligence committee
we've also become by default the
technology committee and I think the
national security issue of our time is
the technology competition with China
we've already seen that around things
like 5G semiconductors we're now looking
at issues like new energy and synthetic
biology because in China we have a
competitor that's investing at a rate
that's commensurate with what we're
investing and I'm all for Innovation but
I've been particularly concerned about
Tick Tock my fear is one
Tick Tock collection more information
about you as a user than virtually any
other site around your keystrokes your
facial expressions and I'm horribly
afraid that that's being stored
somewhere in Beijing I'm also concerned
about it being an ability to manipulate
um the flow of information to you
[Music]
surprising thing about being a U.S
senator particularly coming from my
prior job where I was governor there
were some of the then Democratic
Leadership that didn't really love the
fact that I was trying to find a way to
make bipartisan deals the last couple of
years that's been an advantage as we've
put a lot of bipartisan points on the
board
I'm a guy that leaves a political career
or for that matter any career ought to
be measured by what you get done there
are too many men and women I work with
in this job that can tell you what
they're against
but they can't tell you what they've
actually got done I always felt like my
business at the end of the year got
measured by what it accomplished and I
think that ability to get to yes that
willingness to find common cause with
people of Goodwill across the political
spectrum is I hope a reason why I may be
one of the elected officials to watch in
the future
[Music]